non-minimalists
how do we maintain our focus momentum
and motivation throughout the minimalism
cycle i keep thinking the purge will end
but somehow new things always find their
way into our space especially new gifts
we talked about the gift thing already
a moment ago in this episode but
let's uh let's go a little bit deeper on
the gift side of things so we have two
rules in our book love people use things
we have the minimalist gift giving rule
and then we have the gift getting rule
which is a weird thing to think about as
a minimalist you have a gift getting
rule
and really these are boundaries we set
up because if you're unhappy with the
gifts that you get right now quite often
that
has to do with the fact that you haven't
communicated what you actually do want
what would add value to my life people
want to give you gifts why because not
because gift giving is a love language
or whatever they want to add value to
your life and they think one way they
can do that is through a gift well show
them how to be more intentional with the
gifts maybe it's donating money to your
favorite charity maybe it's purchasing
consumables for you a great bag of
coffee or a bottle of wine or a prepared
meal
or an experienced together concert
tickets something like that
you know these things are gifts
but they're gifts that you would enjoy
getting it's different from uh you know
ryan bought me another pair of cufflinks
and now i don't even have shirts that
take cufflinks but he felt obligated to
give me something and now he's not going
to be happy because he gave me something
i don't want now i feel compelled to
take the gift and i'm not going to be
happy with it because there's nothing i
can do with it what's really
a big portion of that is it's my problem
i didn't do a good enough job setting
the expectation beforehand yeah
yeah i i love how
she refers to minimalism as a cycle
because it is a cycle i mean you know
the things that we have today may not
add value tomorrow i think the
psychological dynamic when you receive a
gift that you don't want is that you
feel the person doesn't know you
and so i think i think the the deep like
psychological need is to be known yeah
and and understood yeah to be understood
and so when you receive a gift that
doesn't match you and you realize oh
this person doesn't really know me
and so i would say that there's a longer
journey of making sure that you have
authentic relationships and friendships
where the people in your life who are
giving you gifts actually do know you as
a person
wow that's so true because
i'd say my gift-getting experience is so
much better now
a dozen years into minimalism
but it's also because i've surrounded
myself with people who better understand
me my preferences my desires
and and also just um what's going to
serve me
and and they avoid just buying something
out of obligation
keeping trinkets upon me they know is
actually going to bring the opposite of
what they want it's going to make me a
little anxious a little discontent
but if you understand the people in your
life and the people in your life
understand you
then by that by the very nature of that
your gift-giving experience will improve
along the way
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free